just wins this game it's gonna be over
he will be the winner but if uh it is a
draw
then we will have another game yeah
that's right so magnus he needs to get
one point out of the next two games
that's no given
especially with black
oh wow i was about to say uh magnus is
gonna play super solid he's just going
to try and get into the game and draw
still fine for magnus recovering from
the last defeat but duda has already
surprised magnus on move three with a
really rare option here he's just pushed
this pawn forward one square normally we
see the italian game the spanish game
white bringing out the bishop in a
different direction different angle
but no he's created a safe square for
this white bishop to fianchetto itself
and i nearly never see this at top level
these days yeah really uh surprising
choice by duda it is a surprising choice
now if white were to develop the knight
on the left side of the board
he would have a specialty of
the england women's team
from the early 2000s
we all played it
okay so magnus playing the most
committal move you know challenging in
the center okay but is this the best
it's not the most popular response
that's for sure definitely not the most
popular response nearly always black
brought out the kingside knight to
attack white's pawn in the center but
magnus traded off those pawns and the
reason this is a bit surprising from the
world champion is he's breaking the
rules black's queen came out too early
and after the white knight jumped
forward the black queen which did kind
of bravely enter the center of the board
has forced to stake uh take a step back
so
right now white is ahead of development
why he's developed two nice knights out
there and uh meanwhile black with the
queen that queen might be a big big
target uh throughout the next
phase of the game uh especially in the
late opening early middle game black
might have to lose even more time yeah
with the queen and uh i'm i just check
in the database here and i can actually
see that magnus has played this position
with the white pieces you know he seems
to be like the most universal player
there is he's always got a game with
white or black in the database in these
particular lines and here i'm just
looking at it he played with the white
pieces against levon aronian in the
london classic 2019 and it was a game
that magnus lost so i think that you
know maybe that game made an impression
on him and he's attempting to use lavon
ironian's ideas against uh young
christoph duda okay and it's the game
still following that one definitely and
uh that game continued
by actually white attacking the bishop
by advancing the pawn one square the g
pawn okay so just forcing black's light
squad bishop to lose even more time and
also breaking this really annoying pin
that that bishop on the edge of the
board is creating towards white tonight
and towards the white queen look at that
black bishop very powerful piece it does
make a lot of logical sense here to kick
it away but then again it's committal if
white pushes pawns to push that bishop
back then white king will not feel
entirely safe castling on the right side
uh so duda does not make that commitment
he pushes this pawn forward one square
instead and
actually uh this this kind of opening of
the queen coming out retreating it's
very very popular nowadays with colours
reversed and uh maybe magnus just
accepting the fact black is one tempo
down but white set up with this
fianchetto now less effective maybe
against what black is doing and okay
black backing up his center creating a
nice little pawn chain there
also creating an escape square for
black's light square bishops this is
actually a new move i mean
we don't there's not too many games in
the database as it is only two and uh in
both those games black took the much
more ambitious approach of pushing that
f1 one square further so this is a very
interesting approach from magnus and uh
well this is my favorite thing and it's
happening on the board so the white king
went to the right the black king went to
the left and that means that both sides
are gearing up for an attack and it's
going to be all about who opens up those
lines first who is the one that gets the
first strike in and
it's
really spicy stuff because white has a
lot of trumps and so does black
so white's the kind of plan is going to
be attacking but probably along the
light squares on account of uh white's
amazing
long uh long bishop on the long diagonal
yeah and meanwhile black will just throw
pawns towards the white king
black might play maybe a central central
strategy as well because if you look in
the center of the board black has a very
far advanced pawn controlling a lot of
squares white's pawn structure a bit
more timid at the moment not controlling
as many squares so strategically here
black is doing quite well but black's
king
for now maybe more of a target than his
counterpart uh white's king pretty safe
especially due to that bishop that
javanco mentioned uh parked in front of
it so uh yeah just like parking the bus
this white bishop in front of the king
this is the structure that i love when
i'm trying not to lose uh but then again
duda remember he's in almost a must-win
situation he's not just happy to park
the bus and kind of keep the white king
super safe he wants to throw pawns
towards the black king and i wouldn't be
surprised if he starts doing that now he
took the words right out of my mouth
duder he's through thrown this pawn
forward and this is actually a pawn
sacrifice but if the pawn is captured
magnus really will be playing with fire
uh we have to jump in and show this
because duda he has shown he's no longer
afraid he's confident once again after
winning the last game and evaluation bar
isn't so sure but from a human point of
view this pawn push a very very strong
one and it's obviously ideally designed
to push forward again and kick away the
black knight from its nice defensive
square but if you capture this pawn if
you stop it from advancing for example
with the black queen or with the black
knight uh then white would just take a
timeout for example just defend its
knight and next move this white rook has
got an open file towards the black king
and yes white is upon down but pawns are
irrelevant here it's all about energy
all about dynamism and it's all about
having those active pieces so for
example if black continues developing
just brings a night out a very sensible
move white has a ready-made attack the
rook slides across the black queen moves
and the white knight might jump forward
the white queen might slide across
create this attack on the open line
it looks very scary for black meanwhile
as i mentioned the white king has
a safe haven and wow magnus is saying
okay i don't trust you he's getting
greedy and he snapped off this pawn
black is a pawn up but as mentioned the
attack's incoming magnus is gonna have
to defend like a lion if he wants to
save this game because next move white
is threatening to kick the black queen
away and use this open file
this black king is already feeling super
sweaty super nervous about what is about
to happen
i'm really shocked at magnus's decision
actually i that from that pawn for me
was like persona non grata i would not
have touched it at all because you know
yes you want a pawn fantastic but as
david mentioned you know opening those
lines and remember when you want to
attack when you want to hunt the king
you gotta open those lines for the minor
pieces to come in i mean think of uh
lord of the rings scenario you know when
they're trying to break through you know
they are trying to find a way into the
castle they're trying to get into that
path so that the troops can all just
stream into the fortress no no no i
don't like this at all
and look at him
magnus got fearless what can i say you
know he retreats his queen
but not to a square that i was expecting
far away from the gaze of the dark
square bishop he's just like yep
whatever i'm maintaining everything and
uh
well the computer likes it
for black
but the humans uh yeah i don't know i
mean presumably the idea is maybe to
step the queen back one square and just
park itself on the i think the idea is
maybe even to develop the bishop to kind
of challenge for this diagonal just uh
for example if the white rook slides
across maybe the bishop can develop and
it blocks up it kind of plugs this line
so uh less to fear here but also put
some pressure on the white knight and if
the white knight moves out the way then
any exchanges will favor black of course
because black is now one porn up but uh
just to me in this current position uh
you mentioned the computer likes it but
when i study chess when i try to analyze
whether pawn sacrifice is good or not i
always look okay if the computer says
roughly 0.0 and if i'm a pawn down that
means it's actually quite good from a
human point of view it's quite practical
if the computer says you're one pawn
down and it's minus one then okay maybe
i do trust it and maybe there's no
sufficient compensation but here the
computer basically says 0.0
and white is a pawn down so white is
completely fine despite having one pawn
lesson wow duder just in light of this
bishop trying to come out and trying to
create this type of pin some pressure on
this diagonal he said okay yes i'm a
pawn down but i can take a time out i
can just stop you from fulfilling your
plan he pushes a pawn forward covering
this key square and now black's bishop
is stuck it cannot jump to the aid of
its king of its queen and uh some real
threats as ivanka mentioned on this
diagonal and maybe on this file later on
and one thing i should mention to
viewers at home do not get greedy here
as magnus and capture a second pawn
because if you take the second pawn with
your bishop you just walk into what we
call a self pin and uh this is not gonna
end well for example white could even
just win a piece immediately by jumping
back with the knight double attack
attacking the queen and attacking this
bishop one of them will drop off
so magnus instead of ignoring instead of
capturing sorry that second pawn he's
just developed his knight it's now
definitely time for
duda to stop bringing his pieces to the
party maybe starting with the rook or
maybe starting by leaping forward to the
center with his knight gaining more time
against this black queen this black
queen has already moved four times she's
about to lose even more time for magnus
so already in move 13 this is uh
becoming quite wild then definitely with
the kings on opposite sides as well yeah
this one i'm going to say it now this
one's not ending in a draw it's going to
go one way or the other
if it ends in a draw it will be after
some fireworks yes yeah yeah definitely
we are expecting fireworks on the board
and uh whilst the players are pausing
for thought
well i wanted to share with you some
selfies and johnny slaw is uh watching
the chess and also at the same time
making an airplane model um
very very very sophisticated working
with little bits so
we hope you're enjoying the show johnny
and polly says that she is enjoying the
show by
watching with wine and chess just the
way i like it and she sends us a big
hello from sweden and uh hello to you
too yeah and uh selene cara says
showtime it certainly is yes and uh yeah
this is the perfect word actually for
what is happening in this match you
could have predicted i was expecting
magnus to actually come into the day
with a very solid mentality you know
just uh hold the fort just uh do his
usual stuff i could not have predicted
this
yeah and uh i know magnus has lots of
fans judah of course has the whole of
poland behind him lots of fans too but
for the neutral viewer this is exactly
what the match needed duda to win and
suddenly both players uh kind of
loosened up completely no more kind of
safety first chest just throwing pieces
at each other taking big risks and uh
that leads to show time
white's rook there just slightly
improving itself i'm slightly surprised
white didn't take uh kind of a time out
to improve his other rook but this
also a decent move for now uh the
evaluation bar not 100 sure maybe this
rook move improving white's position
less than other pieces maybe not the
kind of number one priority but magnus
frowning he's unsure what to do because
the attack against the black king
it's gonna
slowly start building and once it starts
it's gonna accelerate so uh he knows
he's got two or three moves here before
duda built up a huge
kind of initiative momentum against that
black king it just seems like magnus
just lost momentum after that move in
the previous game
where he lost that game and now you know
his body language is still sort of
like he's annoyed with himself or making
that move i don't know what it is yeah
you can tell right yeah the top player
is a perfectionist so even if magnus now
goes on to win the final he'll look back
at that one game he'll think ah
i could have had a whitewash i could
have just completely
uh won every single game just knocked
out duda and just kind of asserted his
authority but
suddenly it's really in the balance this
match now yeah i mean you and i were
discussing the second game uh during and
during the the break and
we kind of found a way to win and i'm
sure magnus is thinking about magnets
for magnus yeah and so i'm sure magnus
is actually thinking about that and just
thinking oh if i just slowed down if i
played this we wouldn't even be playing
game three but you know you have to
adapt to the circumstances and that is
something that magnus is able to do
we've seen him do it time and time again
you know he's knocked down but he's like
the you know terminator he gets back up
again he reassembles himself and i love
that song
i get knocked down but i get up again
it's time for 1998 or 97 though oh
i think it's earlier than that right
maybe yeah oh i mean it was the 1998
world cup that's when i it was like the
anthem
but yeah maybe earlier than that the
same france one france 98 yeah and uh
yeah for sure i mean
magnus missing that actually he could
have won in one move it was quite a
simple one just in hindsight and yeah
he'll be kicking himself
maybe now thinking for a couple of
minutes magnus is he just focusing on
the game he's quite good at bouncing
back in general just focusing on the
present moment and just kind of living
in the current position but
if it were me if it were most humans we
would be thinking oh i could have won in
one move i could be down at the good
night pub right now celebrating and yeah
uh yeah magnus needs to just kind of
refocus somehow re-energize himself and
it's not looking that easy um if you
look at black's pieces as well
how are you going to ever go towards the
white king there's just a barricade
there's like a white knight near the
king white's bishop on the light squares
super safe and if you can't go in an
attack is black you purely have to
defend and uh
yeah i talked about parking the bus for
white i think magnus needs to do that
for black he needs to somehow curl up
into a ball
as we see black's bishop now abandoning
all thoughts of a pin black's bishop was
actually on a decent diagonal but it's
going back to the defense it's going to
try and cover some light squares in
black's camp
and uh yeah i'm not so sure i'm a fan of
that one i think magnus could have
delayed this decision but
by the way he needs to do this type of
thing at some point needs to start
retreating just curling up defending
everything i agree with you i'm not a
fan of this bishop move uh for the
simple fact that you know i would have
actually liked it if white had stepped
forward with the pawn and driven that
bishop back force white to spend time
exactly persuading you to play the move
you actually want to play anyway exactly
and i think i i would have been you know
i'm a kind of a little bit of a chicken
by nature and i don't quite like the
fact that the queen the queen is uh
is uh i had been eyed up by the dark
square bishop so i was kind of looking
at moves such as dropping the queen back
one square or
and
okay maybe let's see what magnus has in
store because it's not entirely clear
how duda is going to carry on his attack
yep
so one option we mentioned would be
duda's knight on the left side just
jumping out the way creating that threat
the ivanka alluded to okay there we go
just as i said it he plays it and this
is probably the most natural move in the
position i was also going to say white's
queen could maybe slid across two
squares or kind of centralize herself
the white knight does park itself in the
middle of the board the most natural
move okay i was gonna say the computer
didn't like it but it's uh it's just
kind of changed its mind there there is
a threat however black's queen now
attacked by white's dark square bishop
so black's queen
i'm also like you expecting it to slide
back but just which direction maybe step
up one square uh
step down one square another decent
option and at least here you blockade
white's pawns white's pawns will not
kind of continue their journey fly up
the board towards the black king she
doesn't have too many squares though
yeah you've got to be really careful
that black queen doesn't get trapped
and uh sometimes we talk about the
scandinavian defense the scandinavian
opening and that is actually very
similar to this type of scenario where
the queen comes out really early for
black and quite often if she gets greedy
grabs a pawn she ends up getting trapped
on these few squares so
okay how can maybe duda start bringing
the white knights back towards the black
queen uh how can white bring the rooks
towards the black queen maybe so so the
first move that kind of can cut
comes to mind is basically just attack
the queen jump forward with the knights
see where she goes
and uh you know if she's stepping on the
b line well you know wow ivanka sorry
just to
look at stockfish here stockfish gives
white a huge advantage and it's the move
you mentioned
what could the idea be so you said it's
the most natural right i agree
and uh my idea was just simple i don't
know whether this is a stock fish but uh
the queen is completely trapped here
apart from one square uh i'll say that
first the queen if you look at it uh it
cannot go to any of the squares across
this rank it's all of these squares are
covered by white wow and that is really
frustrating first of all the queen can't
go back this is covered by the white
bishop uh the queen can't go back here
it's covered by the white knight so it
only has one safe square that's to go to
this one but what have we been talking
about the whole time it's this open line
so maybe it's something to do with this
i'm trying to work it out myself um
ivanka
is it a night sacrifice is the knight
gonna break
open black's king position yeah that
feels a bit too brave because there's no
backup for white's pieces uh sorry that
the remaining white pieces they're not
quite ready to attack it must be
something oh my god david i just took a
look okay and it's something incredible
it is something incredible i'm not sure
how humid it is okay it is actually
sacrificing a night that you wouldn't
even expect it is to jump this night yes
you jump that night into the center
and take this one yes
whoa this is like incredible stuff okay
he's played the first move dude but the
first move was obvious it's the
follow-up he doesn't find the follow-up
he doesn't find the follow-up and just
to explain why this was so strong uh
this knight is sacrificed itself in
order to open up this bishop it was a
sleeping giant we talk about the fee and
keto bishop all the time but this bishop
on its diagonal is just going to be
unleashed and become super strong dude
is shaking his head maybe he spotted
that he could have opened up this piece
it does come at the cost of your night
though and if this night is captured
which i think it would be then i think
it's just to maybe
bring the queen out maybe gain some time
check the black king and force the black
king onto this line that we've been
talking about and now you can do your
big sacrifice now sacrifice another
night so duda in order to win which he
maybe could have done would have had to
sacrifice both his knights and the idea
is that this night now no matter which
way you take it with the king with the
queen
it will just walk into a pin pin and win
and the white rook will now win the
black queen so this was three or four
moves deep uh it would have started with
a sacrifice of one night and then a
sacrifice after this move of another
night but duda he was capable of
spotting this that's where we talk about
the evaluation but if duda had seen the
evaluation bar he would have looked for
something he would have realized a win
existed and he would have found it but
it's so hard when you're playing the
world champion to kind of realize that
they've made a mistake and this one
opening up lines towards the black king
was the key even at the cost of two
nights but instead the movie makes
moving his bishop makes the bar go over
to magnus's side yeah and it's just too
slow and also look at this bishop he's
actually blocked the path of its own
rook the rook wants to use this file but
now it's got its own bishop standing in
the way and it's also given magnus one
move to defend and the only thing i can
think of here is moving this knight out
of the way you've got to be really
really careful
as black because this queen is actually
almost trapped again white has ideas of
pushing the pawn forward and trying to
trap this queen for example if black is
slow the white pawn might step forward
at some point and now the white knight
might even jump back trying to trap this
queen uh something along these lines but
magnus he does have this one move so uh
this might be a threat he needs to move
this knight for example trying to find a
safe square this one well he did move it
he did he did move but he actually
played knight takes bishop first okay
interesting he captured this bishop and
now he's moved his knight across but
this is really scary how many squares
does this queen have not many it's only
got one safe square there or it can
capture a pawn so how can white play
ivanka every time now you told me about
this move every turn i'm looking for
this
maybe you can sacrifice the knight
though it's not too late basically maybe
not because now um the reason i say the
black pawn should capture is if the
black knight captures suddenly the white
bishop will swoop in
guarded by its knight and this looks
deadly the black king just too open now
and if the black pawn takes now this
check you force the black king towards
the corner and now again there's going
to be sacrifices maybe on the square
there's going to be night checks maybe
on this square yeah things are stepping
forward
you spotted something over there i know
you can sacrifice on the score on the
for the pool yeah
because if the black king takes then
just step forward with your pawn right
suddenly look at this bishop it's opened
up and the black king is gonna die on
the light squares i don't think there's
any path to survival and also not just
the king will die but the queen is
pretty much trapped if she takes this
pawn remember pin and win the rook wins
the queen
and uh maybe
can we check this maybe uh i think this
possibly is quite a strong move in the
current position knight takes pawn he's
got a second opportunity you missed it
the first time yes it is
it is possible and the uh the
alternative uh which is also equally
strong is actually not to capture the
knight but to kind of put the knight up
for grabs on the g5 square but the theme
is very much the same
so this is one way for white to actually
secure a winning advantage
another way is just actually just to
attack the queen with the pawn which i
think is a lot more human a lot more
natural yep pushing the pawn attacking
the black queen and forcing her to make
a decision let's go back to the players
we're expecting white to jump away out
of the eye line of his own bishop with
his knight even sacrificing a piece and
that would be spectacular and very very
strong i don't think magnus has spotted
it i think magnus thinks he's fine here
but yeah really dangerous position for
black duda actually
finds that sacrifice i think probably
would be the best game
of the tournament yeah i think at least
the coolest move of the tournament if
that white knight jumps out the way
sacrificing itself
and
if he wins this one what a final we've
got on our hands
uh yeah magnus frowny he's either got
the best poker face in the world magnus
or he just hasn't spotted this idea and
i think in a long game for sure magnus
would be on the lookout for all these
threats these checks these captures
everything but in rapid maybe he's just
kind of assuming that duda doesn't have
the time to work it all out because it's
not just working it out you have to
really calculate to the end
because you're sacrificing at least one
night maybe two nights
just to go for the black king wow
this is this is the key moment of the
whole final this one move if dude finds
a nice sacrifice oh wow you guys well
who knows if magnus wins this game then
the match will be over and the
tournament will be over but uh it's
looking good for young christophe duda
we have made it now you guys to a
hundred and forty four thousand dollars
he's winning now dude and uh yes the
value okay the evaluation bar is going
to take a while i was about to say to
finally see the truth but magnus raising
his eyebrows he's still in shock this is
exactly the idea we just showed but a
slightly different version black's uh
bishop now the light square bishop under
fire this knight has to be taken off the
board simply nothing else to do but then
white's queen is going to come out on
the diagonal white's light squared
bishop has been unleashed everything is
in white's favor and uh yeah i think as
the computer starts to calculate deeper
and deeper the evaluation bar is going
to go to white side even more and duda
genius he loves these wild positions we
mentioned it this is a duda type of
position it's not a magnus type of
position and magnus starting to react
finally
he's going to start realizing it's
dangerous for him
wow oh magnus carlsen he lost game two
young christopher do that tying the
second match and if dudeo wins this
match we're gonna head to tie breaks and
there the bar goes up for duda finding
that incredible move
he has four and a half minutes left on
his clock
magnus has more time magnus has more
time but he's gonna burn that time now i
think because
it's much more difficult in terms of
kind of working out how to defend than
it is how to attack now duda has this
move was the difficult one now he's
worked this one out he's seen three or
four moves into the future white's ideas
are very straightforward so dude is
going to be able to play quickly magnus
on the defensive he's going to have to
spend that time just figuring out how to
survive and just the depth kind of the
deepness of this idea is showed by how
long it took the evaluation bar to react
in white's favor
it's so complicated this uh this one
still i'm not writing off magnus if
judah is careless for one move then duda
might just end up a knight down his
sacrifice will not be justified he needs
to continue being energetic but
ivanka this idea you mentioned
jumping out the way with his knight
absolutely fantastic
i'm not even sure whether it would have
entered my radar i mean i i think i
would have spotted it in a long game a
classical game yeah maybe in a classical
game maybe if it had been an exercise in
a puzzle book where i knew why i had
something there
but i think my eye would have been drawn
to those pawn pushes and i would have
picked up the pawn and maybe attacked
the queen i agree that's also a natural
move and you mentioned also pretty
strong
but that's why we say to ourselves right
always look for checks captured threats
white had no checks in the position
previously white had a couple of
captures one of them was quite strong
but the next one we look for is always
threats
if you create threats your opponent has
to react to them so you gain time so
white is giving up a whole night for
free just for time
and he's going to gain not just one move
two moves he's going to get three or
four moves white the white queen's going
to come out check or it's going to
capture something throw pawns forward
towards the black queen black literally
has no time to react it's every move
he's on the back foot
wow
what a game and before it goes
completely
poco loco isn't that what you say for a
crazy game uh i have to remind you guys
that only 34 minutes is left in our
final auction for
uh our fundraiser for unicef the
chessboard signed by magnus carlsen
current bid
100
and the air thinks device signed also by
magnus carlsen
1025.34 minutes to go to make your bid
all money goes to unicef and we have
some moves we have some moves and as
expected that white knight was just too
strong it was attacking black's light
squared bishop so it had to be
eliminated black did go and capture that
piece white queen immediately darted out
that queen opened up on the diagonal
gaining time as we mentioned checking
the black king the black king hiding so
now next step for duda
open up that king it's that simple you
have to open up the black king remove
some pawns in front of it and uh there's
a couple of ways to do that we mentioned
maybe jumping forward with the white
knight sacrificing not just one night
but two
that would be very brave by duda
there are some alternatives you could
maybe push a pawn forward attacking the
black queen first
options and that's maybe one thing that
could get induced way
i mentioned that his moves are obvious
but there are two or three plans it's
just putting them together in the right
order ivanka what do you think white
should start with
yeah i mean it's i think it's also very
tempting to push the pawn forward and
attack the queen because also ideas you
have in your pocket is also maybe to
give a check with the knight
especially because the queen doesn't
have too many squares if she jumps
forward then we have a nice
straightforward idea of opening up the
the b line and david's going to
highlight it and i really do like this
move yeah hitting the black queen and if
the black queen captures this pawn as
you mentioned this idea opening up the
line for the white rooks the white rooks
are coming and they're going to break
through to the black king and if the
black queen steps back then you just
have to work out what happens after this
knight check it's a fork after all
attacking the king a royal fork
attacking the queen as well so the
knight has to be removed and now the
white queen swoops in attacking this
bishop and
it looks very scary for black but you
have to continue calculating the black
king not quite trapped on the back rank
maybe the black bishop can jump out
attack the white rook
so much to work out here it might be
very good for white or black might be
surviving and black does have
temporarily a bit of extra material so
uh duda this is one option attacking the
black queen uh you could kind of flip
the move order you could give this check
first maybe same idea just different
order uh another option as we mentioned
knight takes pawn but then you do have
to really work out the details because
you're giving up two pieces not just one
uh okay he gives the check uh basically
the same idea we just showed there but
remember the black king if it moves out
of the check then the queen might get
trapped the white pawn will step forward
and the black queen only one square this
walks into yet another attack and look
at these rooks you'll never see two
stronger rooks in an attack
because their vision here is going to
blow the position open it's not just
that but look at this bishop finally
after all those sacrifices you've driven
the black king onto its diagonal and the
bishop as well is going to participate
and win this game it does almost feel
like what has a checkmate in the air you
know the black's king is completely
dominated can't move so very dangerous
position so you do have to capture that
night but the bar goes to zero and young
christophe he shakes his head yeah he
shakes his head maybe he's just trying
to calculate this uh this position often
chess players another reason they shake
their head is not necessarily because
they're unhappy it's just because
they're so confused and this position is
very confusing because there's so much
happening on every turn i think magnus
smiling there wow imagine what a crazy
moment smiling and then frowning he has
to eliminate this night anything else i
think losers on the spot maybe we can
get stockfish's suggestions up here to
confirm i think you have to take this
knight off the board anything else you
lose and
wow he can go to the corner according to
the computer but that looks so inhuman
so suicidal going into the corner as we
mentioned going and but it's not very
practical and it feels like you're just
playing with fire i wouldn't even dream
of that possibility black king is just
too much of a target here
kind of linear and diagonally it's just
okay he does give up his rook i think
that was what magnus had to do giving up
the rook for the knight eliminating an
attacker and notice how this bishop's
attacked if it goes to a safe square for
example then background checkmate the
king is trapped and this ends the game
but instead magnus counter-attacking not
able to move that bishop he jumps out
and hits the white rook this is still
chaotic i think duda should keep the
pieces on i don't think he should trade
uh by capturing this bishop uh suddenly
we'd see everything start disappearing
from from the board maybe white's doing
well with an active queen but at least
the black king is safe i think you need
to keep up the attack and duda does that
uh in the current position bringing his
rook across i mentioned the two rooks
being super strong still loads of
threats against the black king
ivanka predictions are all predictions
off in this position they're off david
uh
so difficult even to find a move
for for black because you know
both bishops vulnerable you know if you
step forward with the light squared
bishop i mean i can only really see one
square it can go to yeah which is to
relocate itself to a different diagonal
yeah black's lights go bishop attack but
also white is maybe threatening to
capture the black knight with his bishop
and yeah open up the blinds for the
whites exactly and if that's the big big
issue then you can't play that you
actually have to over protect your
bishop
your dark square bishop but then you
know there's a rook pinning the bishop i
mean it's such an unpleasant position
and he
does reinforce the protection of the
dark square bishop
but at the very least now very minimum
duda can just use the white queen pick
it up bring it across two squares and
take black's light squared bishop for
free and actually duda would be a
head-on material there and with an
attack going on so plus three for white
now according to the computer that's why
we were so kind of enthusiastic about
white's chances because black is the one
defending and it's so much harder for
black to defend than it is for white to
attack
and uh yeah i think magnus even if he
had half an hour on the clock there he
would have struggled to find the best
moves computers are the only ones who
could ever dream of defending this
position duda meanwhile he's is he
trying to be more ambitious is he
looking for something else i think i
would just take that bishop off and uh
yeah move first and think later
it's a free piece after all yeah it is
also tempting just to step forward with
sea porn and try and win the dark square
bishop as well which bishop to go for i
know i but i also agree with you i think
i would just uh capture the light square
bishop because it's not just a light
square bishop that's falling as well
it's also pawns and uh well dude
oh wow takes the knight he's got a
really cunning idea in mind actually i i
ruled this one out automatically i
thought the black queen could go back
and recapture this bishop but white
would win instantly
dude surprising us surprising magnus
maybe even stronger than what we
suggested we have to show this because i
think he's about to win duda i think
magnus is on the brink now he played
bishop takes knight and magnus didn't
even capture this bishop if you take him
with the queen after a queen trade it
looks like black has two bishops versus
just one rook but white wins by removing
the defender of this bishop rook takes
pawn incredible move this bishop is
pinned so it can't move and next move
you simply capture it you win a bishop
you win the game uh for example if it's
defended again you can remove this pawn
because the bishop cannot
jump out of the pin so queen trade
wouldn't have been possible there if
black had captured this bishop with his
pawn then now white would simply capture
the black bishop and due to this pin
black is going to lose a second piece
after the pawn steps forward and wins
this piece
so magnus just uh ignoring it wait one
second so like
you you could temporarily be uh
okay pushing pushing your phone
attacking the bishop and just thinking
that he could potentially be
a whole work down
magnus magnus yeah this is you might be
a rook down and being attacked
this is not ideal in anyone's uh in
anyone's book so now this bishop is
under fire notice how this bishop still
cannot move if you move it out the way
your queen drops behind and uh still
this pin is just deadly it's all about
the rooks and black's bishop here under
fire black bishop here under fire
i think it's game over i think magnus is
going to resign any moment i just can't
see a way to survive wow for example if
you move this bishop out the way as
ivanka mentioned there's just no good
square if you drop the bishop back you
walk into a nasty check on the back rank
and just no safety here in the current
position dude has done everything right
this is a bit of a masterpiece so far
from him now how impressive turn around
yeah totally turn around and uh guess
what only 24 moves have been played
i mean how often does magnus even lose
and in 24 moves right
and this is also his second loss in a
row so this is going to upset the world
champion okay so he
defends his his bishop with the rook but
okay porn takes bishop on the board and
still that attack is brewing for
duda
and now he's he's gonna go broke down
he's he's currently a whole rook down
there magnus carlsen and with this last
move attacking the black rooks the white
queen about to win even more pieces
magnus just resigns
game over duda striking back fighting
back he's now in the lead today
wow
wow and what a comeback by young
christoph duda